snapple had a moment i'll give you that  switch you know we ran the 90s and 2000s  right what are you talking about  arizona to me tastes like homemade iced  tea and i don't mean that in the good  way i think you do it's like bathtub gin  type  arizona icy tastes like when you used to  take this powder and and stir it up and  make it real like sweet and it was like  oh my god snapple feels like it was made  by artisans no yeah that's quick you all  have an artichoke snack please some of  them i'm saying you have two good  flavors and that's such a joke that's  what i think  that's what i think you think snap  snap pick a lane yeah pick it up  in the middle baby let's go so we're  getting nuts start the wrangler let's  talk about the snapple facts because  we're glossing over yeah one of the  greatest games to take over possibly  talking about lies you want to talk  about lies that's all they are here's a  fact snapple sucks  how long you've been sitting on that one  fatty about an hour